bienvenue bienvenue en moldavie
saine et sauve à cette famille de kiev
est parvenu à s'échapper elle vient tout
juste d'arriver dans la capitale moldave
je suis tellement fatiguée j'ai besoin
de reprendre mes esprits
on m'a dit que les bombardements
allaient s'intensifier dans les
prochains jours alors j'ai décidé que
c'était le moment de partir
grâce à l'aide de la communauté juive
nous avons pu arriver ici
la synagogue leur offre un toit
provisoire et leur facilite les
démarches en vue d'un départ en israël
la loi du retour garanti à tous juifs le
droit de s'y installer
mais avant la guerre ces ukrainiens n'y
avait jamais songé
j'ai un cousin du côté de ma mère en
effet
on ne s'est pas vu depuis 40 ans
on espère pouvoir de retrouver
ce serait déjà ça
israël s'apprête à accueillir des
milliers de juifs ukrainiens le plus
grand affluent depuis la chute de
l'union soviétique